hey YouTubers it's Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Walking Dead Q&A generally I
think everyone's pretty excited for the
mid-season finale little sad to see it
come so soon but I think the things that
they've set up the things that they've
teased are actually going to be really
exciting someone's definitely going to
die still kind of 50-50 on which person
it's going to be but I think you know
their top two picks everyone pretty much
has in common so just careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet but here we go let's get
started with some questions
question number one George Rocka asks
what happened to Rick's revolver I think
that we would find that back with Carl
at the church he had a whole spread of
weapons back there with Michonne Rick's
revolver is like a really famous gun and
he's slowly passing the mantle to Carl
like Carl's becoming a man so he's
starting to wear Rick's hat so why not
take his gun too I think the more
practical reason for him using that gun
is it probably just has more bullets in
the clip but I'm not a gun expert or
anything like that question number two
little Hill asks Kota is a term that
generally means finale since Beth has
been singing several times in the show
do you think it's a cute way for the
producers to hint at her death in the
mid-season finale and do you think that
we're going to have a huge truckload of
survivors moving to Virginia at the end
of the episode I definitely think that
they're going to be heading to like the
next big place like they'll be leaving
Atlanta for sure in terms of who's going
to die I think they want us to think
that Beth is going to die the problem
you run into with Walking Dead is that
because it's adapted partially from the
comics there are so many people that
feel like they know what's going to
happen in advance so I feel like Scott
gimple Robert Kirkman the writers try to
do everything they can to create a lot
of mystery like they want to give Beth
the big win of saving Carol but Carol
doesn't look like she could limp out on
her own at least without someone's help
add to that that Dawn is mysteriously
starting to be nice to Beth even though
the doctor says that that's all bull
crap and I think I may have mentioned
the music stuff in my last Walking Dead
video but Emily Kenny in real life has
been doing like a whole bunch of other
projects now I mean they did rap the
season so it's like all the actors are
free to do whatever they want in the off
season but she's been doing so much
music stuff lately on her social media
that I do kind of wonder if she's
rolling into like a music career I mean
if Norman Reedus can shoot films in
between Walking Dead Seasons then surely
Emily Kenny can do music but anytime an
actor just like surges onto social media
you do start to wonder we're within like
a week of the finale so I'm actually
pretty amazed that there haven't been
liberal spoilers about who actually ends
up dying of all the people that could
die there have been a lot of pictures
from the set recently of them on the set
but like I said that could totally be
for flashback scenes question number
three o well asks do you think it's
possible Carl might kill off Gabriel
because he thinks that he's a liability
to the group I don't know like Carl's
been all about believing in the best in
people so I don't think if I mean if
anyone were to kill Gabriel off I don't
think it'd be Carl it'd probably be
Michonne she's kind of acting a little
bit more like Tyrese Lately too like
let's try to kill less people so I think
if Gabriel ends up dying it's going to
be because of a walker or someone else I
don't think that Carl or Michonne are
going to kill him if anyone were to kill
him because they felt he was a liability
I feel like it would be like Rick
leaving him behind like they would
murder him they just wouldn't bring him
along question number four seam monkey
lad ask am I the only one that wants to
see Bruce Campbell make a cameo yeah
give me some sugar baby um I think if
Walking Dead turned into a comedy he
would totally show up they are making an
evil dead TV series with Sam Ry so I
think the odds that Bruce Campbell would
show up on Walking Dead just went down
dramatically usually actors and
producers are pretty open to stuff like
that it's just scheduling that gets in
the way Robert Downey Jr and Chris Pratt
said that they want to go on Agents of
Shield but because they're such big
actors they're literally booked 247
question number five Chloe ask do you
think the nail going through Gabriel's
foot is anything serious if he doesn't
go back to the group and get help there
could be an infection so yeah that was
actually I felt like it was a little bit
of an iconography of the Christ wound
like you know Christ got pierced through
his feet and through his hands so I felt
like it was a little bit of that too in
the teas for the next episode we see him
limping to the school where the hunters
were where they were eating Bob's foot I
don't think he's going to get very far
on his own and they're not going to do
like a complete separate storyline with
Gabriel in the back half of the season
so he's going to have to cross paths
with someone else I don't think he's
going to lose his foot so I think that
they will treat it at some point whoever
he runs into either he'll go back to the
church with Carl and Michonne or he'll
run into someone like Morgan question
six Alice asks do you think that the
season could end in Alexandria or is it
way too early to tell I mean it is early
to tell it feels like that could be like
a finale moment like they arrived just
in the finale I do think there are a
couple other places that they're going
to show up in the back half of the
Season like they teased a couple other
locations I did hear about a spoiler
place from the comic books so I'm not
going to say what it is but if you read
the comic books there's like a place
supposedly Robert Kirkman spoiled it
during season 2 and up to this point
they skipped it so it's like a place
they've already been in the comics Scott
GLE said that they would be doing things
from earlier in the comics like right
now they're just past the hunters in the
comics which is like you know mid-60s in
terms of issues so they're going to go
to a place that comes from like those
first 60 issues that they skipped over
that's supposed to be like one of the
next big locations so I think that
that's going to occur somewhere around
the middle of the back half of the
season and that'll be the place they go
to before they go to Alexandria but I do
think eventually they will get to
Alexandria question number seven Zoo
asks let's say Rick's attack on the
hospital successful and he kills all the
cops who will be the new bad guy well
this episode kind of teased that Rick
might be the new bad guy like or the new
Shan but I don't think that's the case I
think they just want to mess with our
heads a little bit I think the next bad
guy they'll meet whenever they get to
their next big location like I don't
think that the big big villain is going
to carry over from the mid-season finale
I think they'll leave the hospital and
we'll meet like a whole new group of
characters in the back half of the
Season question number eight Mike asks
is it me or does anybody else think that
they're just driving in circles how far
did they actually get from Atlanta so
yeah I mean they really are localized to
Georgia and even though there's really
no boundaries inside the comics because
of the realities of shooting television
and budgetary concerns they just have to
keep things much more self-contained
it's the same thing with Game of Thrones
in the books and on the show it's like
they can only show so many places and it
costs a lot of money to build big sets
so realistically if they were going to
be nomadic and try to survive and go
from town to town they'd probably be in
a new place every single episode but
because it would cost so much money for
them to build all those sets it's just
unrealistic for the TV show I know for
me it's not really something that I
think about all the time but like every
couple episodes I do kind of Wonder I'm
like thinking about the map in my head
I'm like how far away are they from
Atlanta right now like how come they
haven't been there more often like
clearly there's probably more supplies
in the city usually the television show
comes up with creative ways to explain
why they do stuff like that like the
vatos in Atlanta like that was a reason
for them to leave otherwise staying in
the city probably would have been the
safest bet but then they probably would
have ended up on Dawn's crew just think
about that that'd be crazy question
number nine Cody ask what about Morgan
the show's teased him enough that I
believe he'll be relevant this season
possibly the next episode episode but
they haven't shown him a whole lot and
he is heading towards the group yeah
there are a couple options with Morgan I
feel like it would be a big payoff like
a big WTF moment for him to show up in
the finale it's possible that they could
hold him to the back half of the Season
like he does have a story this season
you know across 16 episodes Scott gimple
just said that it's mostly going to take
place offscreen like they do have a very
clear plan for Morgan but the best
theories I've seen so far are that he is
related to Noah and since Noah doesn't
seem like he's going to be a season
regular like he's not going to be in
every single episode that would be a way
to get Noah off screen like he would go
off with Morgan I would like to see
Morgan with the group though for a
little while like that would be a lot of
fun the last time we saw him it was just
him and Rick it's just that when Scott
gimple was talking about Morgan after
that first episode he said that Morgan
has become a lot more socialized and
used to other people so he's heading
towards groups of people just teasing
the idea that he might travel with the
group for a little while if that were to
happen obviously that' have to happen in
the back half of the Season just because
we we only have one episode left
question number 10 Jerry asks maybe Beth
actually killed Carol without her
knowing Dawn and the doctor worked
together no I think that they wanted to
give Beth the win like that big win of
saving Carol that could be a big note
for her to go out on like if Beth is
going to die then they'd probably want
to give her the Carol save like let her
go out on a big big moment I don't think
that they would demonize her character
too much by accidentally having her kill
Carol like that would be such a downer
ending and even though the Walking Dead
does do that like they do have really
Downer endings I think that if Beth were
going to go that they would leave her on
a high moment as for Dawn's character I
do love what they've done with her like
she's not straight up evil it just seems
like she's slowly losing her mind like
they wanted to tease us with the idea of
everyone walking away and sleeping in
their own beds but then the policeman
escaped and clearly half of the hospital
hates Dawn so that's going to turn into
a [__] storm and Rick is totally on edge
so clearly a bunch of people are going
to die both police officers and a couple
of the survivors or at least one of the
survivors right now I think that only
one big character is going to die
obviously between the top two that I've
been talking about it is totally
possible that both of them could die
though I'm always impressed when a show
can surprise us even when there's so
much cannon from the comics that we have
to look at like we can say you know this
happened to these characters and it kind
of looks like they're doing this
storyline with this character I'm
generally expecting to be surprised
thank you so much though for submitting
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do because next week is the finale
I'll try and do a top 10 video and I'm
probably going to double the giveaway so
I'll just be giving like two Amazon gift
cards away which actually reminds me
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner worry page you win the $20 Amazon
gift card just contact me on my channel
for details so lots of stuff happening
in the offseason to after next week I
will be doing bonus videos The Walking
Dead's not going to be off the air that
long but feel free to leave requests for
specific Walking Dead bonus videos that
you really want to see and be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'll
continue the weekly giveaway so don't
worry about that my next video is going
to be Gotham and then the flash is
tonight so lot of finales happening in
the next couple of weeks so be sure to
stay up with TV catch up if you need to
just a quick reminder if you're watching
on your mobile phone or on your tablet
there's new mobile links up here it's
the same as the links that I put over
here but click here for my episode 7
video and click here for my episode 6
video thank you so much for watching
let's all high five I'll see you guys
tonight